let's talk 2024 for a moment here in the
latest in the Republican effort to
position themselves for a possible race
for the White House but first we've got
to tell you about former president
Donald Trump who fired up his supporters
at the annual rally of conservative
activists known as CPAC there he is
other potential 2024 candidates were
there too but notably not Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis who chose a
different audience at the Reagan
Presidential Library there he is Robert
Costa has more now on the fight for the
Republican nomination we will evict Joe
Biden from the White House former
president Trump back before the
conservative political action conference
this weekend pushing forward his bid and
pushing back in Stark terms against
ongoing investigations I am your Warrior
I am your Justice and for those who have
been wronged and betrayed
I am your retribution Trump also pledged
to stay in the race even if indicted in
one of the state or federal probes of
his conduct I wouldn't even think about
leaving the list of potential Trump
Challengers is long but former Maryland
governor Larry Hogan a trump critic
tells CBS News he will not run I was
struggling uh because my heart was
telling me to run my head was telling me
no politically by staying out of the
race it's a smaller field maybe tougher
for Trump to get the nomination I didn't
want to have a pile up of a bunch of
people fighting Nikki Haley others are
pressing ahead former U.N Ambassador
Nikki Haley announced her candidacy last
month and also appeared at CPAC if
you're tired of losing put your trust in
a new generation notably absent at the
conservative Gathering was Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis who continued his
book Tour on Sunday in California with
no mention yet of his 2024 plans so in
Florida we say very clearly we will
never ever surrender to the woke mob as
for the Democrats President Biden has
still not officially announced his
re-election bid but he did get his first
Challenger on Saturday self-help author
and 2020 candidate Marianne Williamson
announced she will run again I see this
campaign as challenging a system
President Biden's top allies tell CBS
news that he will not engage much with
Ms Williamson's campaign and former
Governor Hogan he said his decision
wasn't part about keeping that group of
traditional Republicans in the party
from crowding each other out and perhaps
making it easier for former president
Trump to use his consistent base to win
that nomination jurika still very early
and a lot could change thank you Bob